eight hundred dollars versus eleven
hundred dollars is it worth spending the
extra cash well that is the first
difference between the 15 and 15 Pro and
I have a total of 20 to share with you
guys number two are the materials now
regular iPhones have always come with
aluminum frames whereas the pros came
with stainless that were more durable
but heavier with the 15 Pros though we
have titanium which is even more durable
and it is also lighter and the next one
is comfort and size both have curved
edges which is really nice for Comfort
but this year the pro is actually
slightly smaller than the regular model
and usually the other way around and
thickness wise it's a very little
difference which is nice but that leads
me into number four and that is the
camera bumps usually the pros have
bigger ones but this year they are
massive and they stick out a ton which
means it's actually quite a bit thicker
there you're going to get a lot more
wobble number five is the action button
and that helps with usability this is
something brand new where you have extra
commands that you can do without having
to actually turn on your screen and go
into settings or press a certain button
to enable an app or a feature that is
built right in and that is quite nice
now number six are the cameras now the
iPhone 14 Pros got the 48 megapixel
camera and that was a major Improvement
but this year the regular 15 also has a
48 megapixel sensor and that is going to
be really nice now the difference is it
is a smaller sensor which is why the
camera bumps I just talked about aren't
anywhere near as large now the pro does
get a 3X lens and has support for apple
raw and prores but with that said the 15
lineup is still going to be a nice
upgrade from the previous iPhone but
camera upgrades only do so much if you
really want to step up your game without
even needing a new phone check out the
insta 360 flow the best gimbal for
iPhone with smooth AI tracking I love
the foldable all-in-one compact design
that takes just seconds to use or put
away and it's genius built-in tripod a
full-on selfie stick as well as a tripod
mount the AI tracking is incredible with
just your support to enable deep track
3.0 which tracks you super well and
unlike others it doesn't freak out if
you go out of frame and it is smart
enough to wait and not track other
people and then re-identify you when
you're back in frame you can even use
zooming and tracking as well as slow
motion tracking and all the recovery
features still work the Smart Wheel
gives you so many physical controls and
the software is packed with features
like 360 photos hyperlapse and much more
while being super easy to use with
all-day battery life so if you're ready
take your videos and photos to a level a
camera upgrade can't do check out the
amazing insta360 flow using the link in
the video description number seven is
lidar for AR applications and it also
helps photos it's something that has
always been exclusive to the pros and
number eight we are moving into displays
now thankfully the 15 is going to get
the dynamic Island that we've had for a
year on the pros and that is great but
the pro will also have thinner bezels
one and a half millimeters it's pretty
much half of the 15 so the screen will
look larger next we have the 2 000 nits
of peak brightness compared to 1200 on
the regular 15. this is great for
outdoor use and for HDR video that is
also a lot better even though both have
OLED displays now with that number 10
the speakers will sound better every
year even though you have the same size
Apple puts in better speakers on the pro
and it's definitely noticeable louder
better bass that is a plus us if you
like listen to music and watching videos
on your iPhone now 11 is the always on
display I absolutely love this feature
and apple keeps it exclusive to the pro
lineup number 12 is the screen refresh
rate now this is a huge deal for me
having promotion with 120 hertz that can
also go down to 1 hertz compared to 60
well it is super smooth and it saves
battery life for number 13 we have the
base storage now for the 14 lineup both
phones came with 128 gigs of storage but
now for the extra price you're gonna get
256 so double and with that the maximum
is gonna be two terabytes compared to
512. now I don't know who needs two
terabytes of storage but some people
will pay for that and it is exclusive to
the Pro phone for the next one we have 8
gigabyte am compared to six now with the
14 lineup we had six on both which was
weird usually the regular one has less
but with this next phone you are going
to get more RAM so it's going to be able
to keep more applications open in the
background instead of having them Auto
close and this leads us up to the reason
why and that is number 15 the a17
processor compared to of course the a16
a generation behind we have three
nanometer compared to four nanometer and
this new Chip is going to give us more
performance it's going to give us less
heat and that's going to also save
battery life which is going to be really
really nice especially if you're
outdoors and the screen is dimming for
that heat aspect of it now number 16
ties into it the battery capacity we're
seeing 3650 milliamp hours compared to
3877 so a larger battery and it's going
to use less power for some of the other
things that we talked about which is
going to be great now with that number
seven is the charging speed we are
seeing 35 watts of fast charging
compared to what Apple advertisers is 20
but in reality you can actually hit 25
if you have a fast enough charger that
also means you'll be able to charge up
your phone faster and now for number 18
we have new Max save now we know they're
going to do a 20 watt Max safe and
there's a chance that the pro is only
going to do 20 watts and they're going
to keep the regular iPhone at that base
15 even if you buy a new Puck that's
capable of outputting more power which
is just kind of a sucky thing when you
know that you could get more and for
number 19 this is a big one both phones
are going to be moving to USB type c but
the regular iPhone is still going to be
USB 2.0 which has been around for over
over 10 years compared to Thunderbolt
for the first time ever in any phone on
the 15 Pro now if you're gonna need to
transfer footage photos back up this is
going to give you over 100 times faster
real world transfer speeds and that is
going to be amazing because so far these
iPhones have been limited and that's
going to be really awesome for me
personally and the people are saying
that you're gonna have to buy the cable
separately it's not going to come with
that fast Cable in the box and it makes
sense those cables are expensive and not
everybody will need it let me know if
you care about that down in the comments
below and for the last one number 20
that is the colors now we've always had
a difference in colors the pros come
with less options and they're more
subdued but this year they are dropping
gold so it's going to be even more
simple compared to The Brighter color
options of the iPhone 15 lineup we're
gonna have some new colors I personally
love their red how it pops whereas the
pros have more basic simple colors and I
really wish Apple would step it up and
give us something a little more
interesting I would love to have a red
Pro iPhone so there you guys go there
are 20 differences between these two
phones let me know if you're going to be
spending the extra 300 bucks to go with
the pro compared to the regular iPhone
where the price tag is staying the same
go ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out the insta360 flow
down in the description below the thing
it really really amazed me and I'm going
to be using it when I'm shooting with my
phone check out the video right over
there and I'll see you in the next one
foreign